amanda bynes takes the first step in
ending her conservatorship after nearly
nine years
e.t can confirm the she's the man star
filed a petition to terminate the
conservatorship of her person and estate
which has been overseen by her mother
lynn bynes the former actress filed the
petition at ventura county superior
court on wednesday a hearing has been
scheduled for march 22nd and e.t has
reached out to bine's lawyer for comment
as for how long it may take for the
termination here's what tamar armanik
the lawyer who represents bind's parents
told et about the process in general
back in 2019.
the first hurdle really is for the judge
when can the judge fit this in the court
system is so congested right now there
would be a hearing a whole process it
could take as much as a week to two
weeks it's almost like a mini trial
where each side would be able to bring
in subpoena their witnesses bring in
their documents
and show and prove their
case bain's conservatorship began in
2013 giving mom legal control over her
from personal and medical decisions to
financial affairs the move was made
after the then 27 year old was
hospitalized on an involuntary
psychiatric hold in 2014 the water girl
1 star revealed she was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder
the star's sudden spiral came as a shock
to long time fans of vines who largely
seemed to be able to avoid these
so-called child star curse well i i
really i don't know i feel like i i've
never been into that kind of thing and
i go to a party every now and then for a
good cause but other than that i'm not a
big partier but i have fun you know i'm
21 i live it up but other than that i i
you know i try to focus on my work in
recent years bias has kept a low profile
and been in and out of mental health
facilities the nickelodeon alum last
gave fans an update on her life back in
2020 when she shared she'd been in a
two-month treatment program she also
revealed she was engaged to and
expecting a child with paul michael they
met in a sober living facility soon
after bayern's lawyer told e.t that she
was not pregnant and that she was in a
safe location and doing very well
and last april the former child star
turned 35 at the time et learned she was
doing well and leading a quiet life
living near the beach attending fashion
school and working towards earning a
bachelor's degree
[Music]